overall we constantly face generalized
accusations
uh which we that that we can't be
trusted and that we aren't a reasonable
international actor
so with all this in mind we can't help
taking it with a bit of a pinch of salt
when we're told the eu has stopped
thinking about the uk and it is we who
are still obsessed with brexit
actually we're not there is no electoral
dividend in endlessly talking about
brexit it's quite the reverse that's why
the prime minister barely mentioned it
in his party conference speech last week
what we do see instead is an
organization that doesn't always look
like he wants us to succeed
we didn't want it to be like this we
just want friendly relations free trade
and the chance to do things our own way
all within the framework of a meaningful
and robust western alliance
with this in mind i do urge the eu to
look at the image that's being presented
to us
if there is a trust problem as we're
constantly told there is it's not the
responsibility of only one party
at some point we must both try to raise
our eyes to the horizon
look at the possibilities for better
relations
and try to help each other solve
problems not create them
which brings me to my fifth and final
point
and the biggest current problem between
us
the northern ireland protocol
is the biggest source of mistrust
between us and for all kinds of reasons
we need to fix this problem
i recognize that's not easy the history
here does matter
i do understand whether you find it
difficult to come back to an agreement
that was reached only two years ago
though obviously that in itself is is
far from unusual in international
relations
equally there's a widespread feeling in
the uk that the eu did try to use
northern ireland to encourage uk
political forces to reverse the
referendum results or at least to keep
us closely aligned with the eu
and moreover the protocol represents a
moment of eu overreach when the uk's
negotiating hand was tied and therefore
cannot reasonably last in its current
form
whether or not you agree with either of
those analyses the facts on the ground
are what matter above all
maybe there was a world in which the
protocol could have worked more
sensitively implemented
but the world has now moved on and we
now face a very serious situation the
protocol is not working
it's completely lost consent in one
community in northern ireland it's not
doing the thing it was set up to do
protect the belfast of friday agreement
in fact doing the opposite it has to
change
no one here is expert in northern
ireland and we're not asking you to be
we're asking you the eu to work with us
to help us manage the delicate balance
in the belfast agreement and not to
disrupt it to help us reflect the
concerns of everyone in northern ireland
from all sides of the political spectrum
and to make sure the peace process is
not undermined
the key feature of the belfast of friday
agreement is balance between different
communities and between their links with
the rest of the uk and with the republic
of ireland
that balance is being shredded by the
way this protocol is working
the fundamental difficulty is that we're
being asked to run a full-scale external
boundary of the eu through the centre of
our country to apply eu law without
consent in one part of it
and to have any dispute arising from
these arrangements settled ultimately in
the courts of one of the parties
the way this is happening is disrupting
ordinary lives damaging large and small
businesses and causing serious
turbulence to the institutions within
northern ireland
i remind you burke's words i quoted at
the beginning and i quote again politics
should be adjusted not to human
reasonings but human nature
people must be governed in a manner
agreeable to their temper and
disposition
that is why we need to move on from this
once and for all and that simply won't
happen without significant change to the
existing arrangements
we put forward proposals to fix things
in july
they are less than many in northern
ireland would like to see
they don't sweep away the protocol they
work with the grain of it
they don't require infrastructural
checks at the international border
between northern ireland and ireland
noah wants this and we've always opposed
it
they keep rsc trade arrangements for
goods going into ireland and we accept a
responsibility to implement eu rules for
those goods
they would allow uk and eu standard
goods to circulate in northern ireland
they protect the eu's single market
but crucially they would allow goods
also to circulate virtually freely
between northern ireland and the rest of
the uk something that every other
country in the world takes for granted
we're now heading into a crucial few
weeks we await the proposals that are
coming tomorrow from maryl sheffrich and
the commission in response to our ideas
i want to be clear we'll be really ready
to discuss them whatever they say and we
will obviously consider them seriously
fully and positively
but i repeat if we're going to get to a
solution we must collectively deliver
significant change we need the eu to
show the same ambition and willingness
to tackle the fundamental issues at the
heart of the protocol head-on
that's why i'm sharing with the
commission today a new legal text the
text of an amended protocol reflecting
the proposals in our command paper and
supporting not undermining the belfast
friday agreement
and i want to comment briefly on a
couple of aspects of this text
first of all the new protocol that we
are proposing is forward-looking
the original version was agreed at a
time when we didn't know whether there
would be a trade agreement between us
and the eu
many of the most unusual and
disproportionate provisions were agreed
precisely because we didn't know what
the shape of our future trading
relationship was going to be
in the face of uncertainty the original
protocol defaulted to excessive rigidity
rigidity was now needlessly harming
northern ireland
we now have a very far-reaching
agreement between us in the trading
cooperation agreement one which
regulates all aspects of our trade in
the future
so it makes sense to situate the new
agreement in that new trading context
and bring it in line with those
arrangements they are after all the most
significant signs by each party so far
second our proposal looks more like a
normal treaty in the ways governed with
international arbitration instead of a
system of eu law ultimately policed in
the court of one of the parties the
european court of justice i think the
commission has been a bit too quick to
dismiss governance as a side issue and
the reality is the opposite
the role of court of justice and the eu
institutions in northern ireland are
creating a situation where there's no
discretion about how provisions in the
protocol are implemented
the commission's decision to launch
infraction proceedings against us
earlier this year at the very first sign
of disagreement shows why these
arrangements so hard to make work in
practice
but it's not just about the court it's
about the system of which the court is
the apex the system which means the eu
can make laws which apply in northern
ireland without any kind of democratic
scrutiny or discussion
none of this we can now see will work as
part of a durable settlement indeed
without new arrangements in this area no
protocol will ever have the support
across northern ireland it needs to
survive
so i do urge portugal where i am today
everybody in the eu
to to look carefully at what we are
proposing as we will look carefully at
what the eu proposes
i ask everyone listening to me today to
think again about the positions taken so
far
if we can put this protocol onto a
durable footing we've got the
opportunity to move past the
difficulties of the past year we have a
short but real opportunity to put in
place a new arrangement to defuse the
political crisis that is brewing both in
northern ireland and between us
if we can work on that then of course
other things become possible too
other significant problems in the
relationship of interest to both sides
might become resolvable
we would have a chance to move forward
to a new and better equilibrium
the protocol itself envisages it could
be superseded by future agreements in
its article 13 8.
given the experience we now have as
clear as we must be
i ask what does it cost the eu to put a
new protocol in place so it seems to us
very little there's no threat to the
single market from what we are proposing
we're not asking to change arrangements
within the eu in any way we're not
seeking to generalize special rules for
northern ireland to any other aspect of
our relationship
and for the eu now to say the protocol
drawn up in extreme haste at a time of
great uncertainty can never be improved
upon
when it's so self-evidently causing such
difficult problems would be a historic
misjudgment
it will be to prioritize eu internal
processes over relieving turbulence in
northern ireland to suggest that
societal disruption and trade distortion
can be disregarded
perhaps even that they are an acceptable
price for northern ireland to pay to
demonstrate that quote brexit has not
worked
to insist on this route will be to do a
great disservice to northern ireland and
not recognize the process of iterative
improvement that has kept the balance
and sustained the peace process in
northern ireland over past decades
of course the eu can insist on this can
insist on no change but if it does must
remember that it is this government the
uk government that governs northern
ireland as it does the rest of the uk
northern ireland is not eu territory
it is our responsibility to safeguard
peace and response and prosperity in
northern ireland
and that may include using article 16 if
necessary
we would not go down this road
gratuitously or with any particular
pleasure
but it is our fundamental responsibility
to safeguard peace and prosperity in
northern ireland and that is why we
cannot rest until this situation has
been addressed
the protocol itself is clear it respects
the quote essential state functions of
the uk
it does not create some kind of
co-dominion or co-responsibility with
the eu in northern ireland it doesn't
allow the eu to develop its own
aspirations for northern ireland as if
it were a member state for example to
decide that it is northern ireland's own
interests to stay subject to the rules
of single market for goods whatever the
uk government may think
in short the protocol is there to
support the peace process it's there to
support the basis the belfast good
friday agreement
the article 16 safeguards are there to
deal with the situation if the protocol
ceases to provide that support and we'll
always act with that in mind
so repeat to conclude let's let us be
ambitious let's see if we can find a
better way forward
let's agree arrangements which we will
both implement and which can in fact be
implemented because they command
acceptance and respect across northern
ireland
in short let's try and get back to
normal with some effort of will we could
still despite all the problems being a
position where the poison is drawn from
this issue entirely and it is removed
from the diplomatic top table once and
for all
and i personally would certainly be
happy if i could to come here next year
and talk about a new age of cooperation
in which the word protocol never appears
let me return one last time to burke's
pamphlet
he's describing the british government's
position at a previous time of deep
division in british politics in fact he
was over policy on america
but his words have resonance to all of
us today and i quote
a diversity of opinion upon almost every
principle of politics had indeed drawn a
strong line of separation between them
and some others
however
they would desire us not to extend it by
unnecessary bitterness they wish to
prevent a difference of opinion from
festering into rancorous and incurable
hostility
accordingly they endeavored that all
past controversies should be forgotten
i think we should act in that spirit
the western alliance has got too many
global challenges to spend time on
internal disputes we all face the same
problems we all need to stick together
if we have to keep counting for
something in the rest of the world and
making a difference that is what we will
work for that's what this government
will work for and we hope it can be a
genuinely common effort thank you very
much